damit werden hollywood wasser hat
vorjahr
ernsthaft ich finds dem rat der mann
kommt der sally die zelle ist gerade weg
und ich sollte etwas zu essen machen und
wie so oft ist die kids wollen natürlich
was haben und zwar die kids stehen
richtig auf nudeln und richtig auch
würstchen als typisches kids mögen alles
was aus der hand essen kannst da haben
wir gedacht warum nicht nur mit
würstchen kombinieren ihr kennt das
vielleicht schon manche haben das auch
schleichen internet gesehen und ich
würde das gern mal nachmachen
ich habe es mit muss ich ehrlich sagen
noch nie gemacht das heißt wir lassen
uns alle überraschen ich bin genauso
überrascht wie ihr und wir schauen wie
wir das hinkriegen bekommt so fangen was
brauchen wir hier haben mir sagt weck
würstchen und zwar sind die würstchen
vom türken
das ist ein ganz normales ossis wenn
jetzt die türken geht verlangt einfach
nach frischen sources dann haben wir
hier ein liter ungefähr oder 900 gramm
tomaten aus der dose
dann haben wir hier nudeln und zwar
nudeln wie viel nudeln nicht
spaghetti haben wir ja die siegesparty
hammer 263 waren 63 wie seid ihr auf 263
km gekommen ist sondern etwas sagen
hätte auf 64 seiten egal
es hört sich auf jeden fall ganz ganz
wichtig an jetzt haben wir noch zwiebel
warum warum es dann mich drauf sagt okay
das ist eine zahl mit ziegel saft also
eine frist von sieben dann haben wir
nach abu aita gewürz das ist knoblauch
brocken zu blocken
zwiebel flocken oregano dann haben wir
hier
oregano richtig genau okay dann haben
wir hier eine knoblauchzehe und haben
ein würfelzucker brauchen wir diese
würzigen geschmack ok alles klar
damir oliven rapsöl genau
und dann haben wir hier salz und pfeffer
je nach geschmack
dann fahren wir ganz cool wie das fanden
wir fangen an mit der zwiebel schneiden
das macht richtig spaß die jungs haben
sich das vorgestellt finde ich richtig
toll jetzt tumor wie zwiebel einmal
durch die hälfte und einmal viertel
jetzt haben wir
hier helfen ihr viertel danach dann
haben wir hier den ali und zwar dalí
datum jetzt einfach die des teams
perfekt wahnsinn
ich habe dass die war zu groß weil
kannst du zwiebeln ja ganz einfach
würfeln ja so triebel ganz einfach
würfeln genau
danke kommt für diesen hinweis wenn wir
hier mal ein bisschen kleiner und müssen
dann nachher richtig feine würfel
nächsten wahnsinn oder wie der murat das
macht was wir auch ein machen ist
knoblauchzehe so manche frage ist
natürlich wird die knoblauch gepresst
oder wird er geschnitten
ich bin der meinung dass der knoblauch
eigentlich völlig egal ist ob sie
geschnitten drittel fest wirklich sagen
immer das ding hier und tun der panne
das nennt sich übrigens auf französisch
satz war
oder so ähnlich
oliven oder rapsöl ich mich warum rapsöl
oliven gemisch olivenöl gewicht weil du
rapsöl höher erhitzen kannst so und da
mir jetzt ist jetzt anbraten möchten
machen wir hier den binger straße auf
drei langsam erhitzen dass ich jetzt mal
kurz
währenddessen während bis zehn bisschen
aufkochen jetzt hoch auf sowie sechs
genommen tue ich hier das nudelwasser
nudelwasser schon mal ein bisschen würze
wird salzen
warum salzmann nudelwasser das ist immer
so eine frage warum macht man das
weil sie nudeln sonst nix weil dies
sonst noch mehr machen noch mehr rein
weißt du wo hätte ich das heißt woher
weißt du dass ich habe also eine
kurzmeldung ist doch gut wenn jetzt weiß
besser dies könnte auch vorkommen da
kann ich mich auf die laufsachen und die
sportschau in den wolken wenn er lust
hat
was wir jetzt haben wir die nudeln fahne
heißt heißt die panne ist noch nicht
heißt warum nicht weil ich das falsche
feld an gemacht habe zudem kann auch
passieren
wir machen ja mit mich hier einfach ein
rezept der ein paar sachen das heißt
wirklich kochen und backen auf geringem
bildungsniveau das auch wirklich auch
die männer zu hause das nachmachen
können und ja richtig oder genau das ist
ehrlich es ist wirklich ehrlich über
nichts gefällt hier kann alles mal
passieren für uns ist es sehr wohl eine
überraschung immer und jetzt mal sie die
küche aus wie sau
jetzt funktioniert wahnsinniges teil hab
gesehen wie schnell es gemacht habe so
sieht's aus
wahnsinn
ja das gehört mir das zwischenzeitlich
wollen wir das auf dass hier das ja
jetzt wollen wir uns gesagt räumen muss
anbraten und wir fragen uns an
doch wahnsinn oder tom kummer rhein
sieht es nicht schön aus wie der monat
ist an dreht werden wissen wir dass
antreten brannten kannst du wirst du mal
schneiden wir schneiden schon mal die
würstchen und zwar haben wir die
würstchen
ihr könnt natürlich auch wiener
würstchen nehmen jetzt dreijähriges
würstchen
ihr könnt auch deutschland nehmen das
ist auch egal wie es möchte
und jetzt die musik sagt wow
aber die haben ja schon besonderen
geschmack ja wir haben uns war das ein
bisschen schärfer
also wie gesagt einfach zum türken und
sagt einfach ihre stasi source basis
muss ich das heißt einfach frisches und
da könnte ja auch sagen andere und
schiller heißt ja mit dem manchmal in
die wurst panne so jetzt aber die
lustigen geschnitten was machen wir
jetzt
ich hab eine tolle idee ich nehme die
nudeln ja darf ich vorstellen ich war
nicht meine zuschauer
jetzt sind wir mal so 3 0 oder 4 egal
kann man hat und ich stecke mir jetzt
einfach dadurch
das ist eine sehr diffizile
angelegenheit das kann nicht jeder
der jahrelang geld geübt auf jeden fall
ich denke mal 3,4 ein wahnsinn
so sieht auch ästhetisch aus also wenn
ich das ding sehen würde wie ich sagen
jetzt vom sternekoch währenddessen
irgendwas mach jetzt falsch wir machen
das nudelwasser wieder runter man muss
nicht immer alles im auge behalten
werden sprechen alles an
so jetzt kann ich die ganzen nudeln hier
mit den ganzen juli mit richter hin wer
kann auch diese blöde idee heute meine
frage
[Applaus]
[Musik]
während ich die zwiebeln anbraten und
knoblauch manrique hirsch auch schon es
liegt nämlich jetzt nach zwiebeln und
knoblauch
jetzt sind wir hier den den die tomaten
aus der dose und schütten sie mit rein
dabei einen automaten drin was machen
wir jetzt warte man das ding an sich
einige typische tomatensoße zwiebel ein
bisschen knoblauch so jetzt sind wir
hier noch al arabija gewürz und oregano
so jetzt aber ihren würfelzucker
er kam auf die idee mit dem würfel
zucker mal ganz tolle idee so die
gremien klein ganz einfach ich lieber
einen total coolen tricks auf dem ihr
wahrscheinlich keiner gekommen
wir nehmen hier einfach ein bisschen
wasser so seht ihr das ok jetzt haben
wir hier auch alles rein gemacht jetzt
habe ich keine zutaten herr einfügen
können doch mit können doch diesen
zwiebel reinmachen ein bisschen salz ich
mag 100 salz und ein bisschen pfeffer
[Musik]
so sieht es aus wenn ich die ganzen
nudeln jetzt aufgespießt habe die ganzen
bisschen sagt und hier habe ich nebenbei
lasse ich gerade noch die tomatensoße
wurzeln und während die tomatensoße
weiter vor sich hin brüssels macht er
tomaten sonst nichts aus wenn sieben
stunden lang putzen würde nehme ich
diese nudeln mit dem würstchen und tun
sie einfach ins kochende wasser man hier
zum beispiel hier mit 14 ude legal
würstchen rein das ist das ist das ist
deswegen sind wir so erfolgreich wie
männer so wir müssen jetzt gar nicht
machen weil die nudel nennen sie es mal
weich sind dann sagt alles runter genau
und währenddessen römer die tomatensauce
und ein bisschen auf und gleich gehts
weiter
also hier kocht die tomatensoße hier
habe ich diesen koch über schutz drüber
gemacht auch darüber gemacht so und hier
sind nudeln minute sind noch nicht ganz
durch weil jetzt machen ganz ganz tollen
trick und zwar schaut man ehrlich
brothers wahnsinn oder
abgießen und hinüber kopfschutz mutter
sah man das nudelwasser abgießen
blitzeblank da sieht man dass der topf
antihaft beschichtet ist wahnsinn
jetzt haben wir hier die tomatensoße vor
sich hin köchelt jetzt sind wir gerade
noch die nudel die noch nicht ganz durch
sind und tun sie hier rein damit wieso
ist richtig toll aufnehmen
[Musik]
jetzt nicht noch einen weiblichen löffel
und rühren ein bisschen rum aber das
wird richtig lecker
die teams werden sich richtig freuen
jetzt lassen wir es noch mal so ungefähr
fünf minuten noch mal vor sich hin
kirche und währenddessen räumen wir auch
dass die frau zu hause zu bringen wir
sie raus und jetzt sagt marius gleich
probieren
amara ist auch völlig völlig ehrlich ja
also ganz ehrlich also wenn es nicht
schmeckt dann sagt das auch und dann
beim nächsten dreh einfach nicht mehr
dabei ja okay alles klar
marius all das was in wilster marius
marke werden die kinder auch mögen ihr
könnt mit tomaten so ist natürlich
verändern ihr möchtet also von den
gewürzen herren dran
nur ich stimme mit coole geschichte wenn
es natürlich die italiener sehen
nudeln mit mit mit würstchen die sagen
sie bestimmt das kann natürlich nur in
deutschen einfallen
aber kann man nichts machen
ganz cool cool dass euch gut gemacht ja
heißt ich es marius
[Musik]
ein kleines bisschen salz fehlt
vielleicht noch aber sonst ist er in den
marius dann nämlich salz pfeffer hier
deshalb vorher wahnsinn also ein
bisschen mehr salz tomatensoße wird sich
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr wird so gab
es ist auch schnell gemacht und ich bin
halb für die kids ist das wissen was
cool ist also richtig ist ein als
frische sachen frische tomaten aus der
dose auch gut nudeln die würstchen sind
cool ich bin wirklich lustigen ihr wollt
ihr könnt auch pfeffer bei zu nehmen
oder wie auch immer das ist ihr möchtet
also definitiv zu viel wenn du mein kind
wird
wärst du stolz auf papa für dieses
gericht ja also das haben wir kochen auf
geringem bildungsniveau
ich habe hier wie gesagt diese tollen
würstchen gemacht und ich hoffe ihr
start beim nächsten mal wieder ein wenn
es wieder heißt monats fünf minuten
macht's gut
vielen dank und macht's besser
[Applaus]